did you go to Fenway Park and throw out
the first pitch right over the plate and
Varitek car and it didn't touch the dirt
and it was from the mound proper proper
for you for six months to practice for
that when you see Papa flow highs that
was really you you practice you practice
for three months six six months six
months I had a pitch back in my driveway
and then I went to haters barn and
actually add a pitching coach for the
last couple weeks because you didn't
want to embarrass yourself and I wanted
to throw it was very important for me as
a woman to throw from the mound right G
like full full distance were you shocked
by the lack of finesse that pop up who
he himself had I mean here's a guy
claims he was a coach for Little League
and all this does not always mean one is
do you laugh at a guy like this did you
hello I feel terribly uncomfortable and
super embarrassed whenever I see anybody
fail anything I'm like do you machen the
shame I felt when my producer just
missed completely and through it like
Gary be teaching kids to pitch or is
that something that he should not be
doing in your opinion he should be
inspiring them
[Laughter]